vous demandez tout ce qui y est ah oui
le ou la nouvelle chroniqueuse de tpm p
vous demanderez c'est une bonne ou une
mauvaise idée aussi vous la connaissez
bien
c'est une femme elle est déjà venue dans
l'émission entre nous deux
la nouvelle chroniqueuse de tpm pays
c'est
[Musique]
si on devait faire le portrait robot de
la famille des al nabawi franchement ils
se rapprocheraient fortement d'ayem ah
bah ça c'est le portrait craché veille
non j'adore le charme oriental comme ça
les débits noir les yeux bouche pulpeuse
l'effort y adopte la trouve superbe
façon cryptée
[Rires]
jean-michel si vous étiez célibataire je
le suis jean michel est ce que vous
auriez pu être intéressé par à y est m a
complètement mais je le suis abonnée aux
gens c'est pour ça c'est pour ça que
vous êtes aussi beaugas aujourd'hui
contient moi je pense
voilà c'est vrai alors en fait c'est
donc parce que vous vous avez fait en
fait j'étais sûr isabelle vous avez vu
que c'était pas possible mais c'est vrai
après j c méfie toi dans la zone et où
sentimentalement parlant au jeu préféré
parler capillairement parlant non sans
fil pour savoir le rappelle jean michel
est ce qu'elle vous constatez que j'ai
coupé mes cheveux
oui mais donc c'est qu'il ya eu un
changement à un mentalement parlant pour
dire que vous êtes peut-être à la ruche
et non j'ai coupé mes cheveux parce qu
en fait j'étais je fréquentais une
personne qui adorait mes cheveux longs
ah ouais voilà inverse de ce que la
personne m
ah ouais bah tu te comportes
incorrectement j'adore mes cheveux longs
je coupe les veufs
quand une femme change capillairement
parlant ouais y'a quand même un impact
c'est à dire qu elle l a besoin d'un
renouveau d'un truc on s'en fout des
célibataires ou pas
mais sur les rappeler si on les rapides
on part dans les chiens on parle de vous
jean-michel mais oui c'est quoi la
question leur est volée ça on parle pas
de gens missionnaire andrew c est ce que
vous êtes open parce que vous êtes
impliqué e vous êtes closed bon je vous
êtes 50 minutes inside
cyrille germain open c'est très
tendancieux non célibataires ou non mais
oui ben open source et dire oui je suis
célibataire
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je ne veux en savoir plus sur moi mais
les conclusions c'est bon non merci non
au québec merci elle combine juste poser
une question est ce que c'est ni bête
s'est dit célibataire c'est différent de
open open ça veut dire je suis prête à
tout mais pas du tout alors ici on n'est
pas sur l'énergie à ce que je sais que
surya des portes ouvertes toute la
journée les adore en plus de
célibataires oui célibataire oui je vais
vous dire juste pourquoi je pense que
c'est un profil qui n'existaient pas
autour de la table et moi la principale
qualité que je demande un chroniqueur
c'est d'être gentil d'être sympathique
et surtout d'avoir un très bon fond et
dieu tu est une belle personne
ici on voit là on peut dire ce qu'on
veut ici il n'ya que des gentils autour
de la table quoi que ce soit mal
érigeons mikkeli maxime st amour il à
ses ouailles et géraldine on parle pas
raymond c'est mon pote depuis des années
c'est ça mon frère voilà donc c'est vrai
une castaldi c'est un amour de mec et
c'est vrai que moi je ne veux que des
gens gentils qui sont là pour s'amuser
et qui ont un bon fond qui sont pas là
pour faire des calculs et c'est pour ça
qu'à iem je les choisis à la base parce
que un c'est quelqu'un que je trouve
qu'il ya beaucoup de talent qui avait
beaucoup de talent sur nrj nous deux
c'est quelqu'un que je trouve qu un très
bon fond et qui est une belle personne
voilà tout ça donc je me suis dit avec
salle pour bien s'intégrer dans l'équipe
je cherchais également quelqu'un motivé
jean michel et moi je suis quelqu'un
d'honnête j'aime bien parce qu'elle pas
changer du jour au lendemain
moi jusqu'à sur nrj 12
j'aimais pas elle vient ici sûreté pmp
c'est très bien moi quand je suis arrivé
ici tu m'as dit t'inquiète pas je sais
ce que je fais j'espère que tu sais ce
que tu fais pour elle aussi et j'ai
confiance
est ce que vous avez lu les réactions
sur la ligne alun pour être honnête j'ai
tout nu
j'aime twitter j'ai lu instagram j'ai dû
facebook et c'est marrant parce que
c'était très différent surtout tagliani
avait une déferlante de haine et de
mettre alors sur twitter c'est vrai que
sur instagram en revanche c'était très
très positif
donc je peux pas moi je vais pas me
positionner on va parler de moi deux
chats mais vraiment il y avait cité
l'opposé à l'orbiteur c'était méchant et
sur instagram c'était très bienveillant
valérie bénaïm vous ayem bien moyenne
bien
ayem bien parce que on a dans cette
émission il regarde et il faut des gens
qui ont une vraie personnalité
il faut des gens qui suscite des
réactions ce que ce qui est le cas il
faut des gens qui sont qui sont des
grandes gueules qui sont capables d'être
d'intégrer une équipe parce que c'est
une équipe qui est déjà constitué donc
il faut pas être timorés faut pas être
timide où il faut vouloir il faut va
falloir la ramener je pense kayem la
ramène et je n'y a aucun doute là dessus
c'est une vraie personnalité et moi je
veux toujours ce que commande et en
marketing les cessations son produit et
j'ai toujours du mal moi quand on tombe
sur quelqu'un alors qu'il n'a même pas
encore ouvert la bouche en disant ça
sera forcément pas bien alors mais
souvenez-vous de la déferlante
idem pour matthieu delormeau sa
déferlante heures l'identique ouais moi
l'identité une catastrophe que la
téléréalité envahie c'était pmp que
l'émission allait se dégrader
aujourd'hui c'est une valeur sûre
mathieu darche mission et qu'il est très
fort c'est un vrai personnage donc
pourquoi on laisserait pas sa chance à m
ou bien alors isabelle morini-bosc ayem
bien moyenne pas ayem bien me connais
pas bien donc mois jérémy j'ai toujours
entendu parler d'elle et donc je trouve
c'est un personnage intéressant donc moi
ça m'intéresse de la connaître mieux
même s'il n'a pas voulu être à côté de
moi c'est pas lequel choisir si en plus
vous êtes le taulier donc où ça se passe
très bien et on est ravi où ça se passe
bien et c'est vous qui déciderez don
pasquale regard vous un honneur en tout
mais non mais non non non non les gens
là franchement on vit comme un honnête
et dire et ils savent reconnaître un bon
chroniqueur dans mauvais qu'au niveau
maxime guigne ayem bien je pense que
c'est une bonne chose avec ayem on a une
relation compliquée visiblement j'ai
aurait été maladroit tous les mac et je
lui dis quelque chose que la malheur
il avait tenu des propos est comme moi
je suis prêt très spontanée très
authentique
c'est fait la réflexion et ça non plus
pas signer le plus gentil j'espère que
je vais donc rien passé par la suite son
arrivée dans tpm paix avec la tmp family
deux soirs plus souvent j'espère que ça
va dissiper nos mâles nos maladresses
alors bienvenu j'aime pas sur nrj12 cap
zé je n'ai pas du tout aimé les peu de
fois que j'ai mis la télé je l'aimé
parce qu'ils aiment c'est ensuite j'aime
pas trop le personnage parce que le
personnage est idéal il est capricieux
de ce que j'entends mais c'est pareil
c'est ce que j'ai entendu ce qu'on me
ramène des preuves et tous tes
capricieuse tu le sais tu es pris
mission et tu le sais je n'adore ses
vêtements je te dis après voilà ils
disent qu'ils font là je dis ce que je
pense et je suis sûr que tu vas faire
des bonnes émissions aussi parce que tu
es une grande gueule et je sûr que ça va
marcher
moi je vais être tout à fait sincère
effectivement je j'exècre la télé
réalité dont tu es issu je la trouve
vide dégradantes vulgaire avilissante et
ravageuse pour la jeunesse une fois que
j'ai dit ça sans aucun mépris et
condescendance mois a priori en fait
j'ai rien contre toi c'est je suis je
suis contente que tu viennes autour de
cette table pourquoi parce qu'on fait la
force de tes pmp pour moi c'est être une
sorte de patchwork de sensibilité
d'opinion de cursus dans la vraie vie on
se serait jamais rencontré isabelle
raymond kelly gens me et grâce à cyril
effectivement on se rend compte vraiment
là oh oui enfin c'est une ici c'est à
dire dans la vraie vie c'est ridicule
passant puis rallier je la vois pas dans
la grille tout cette émission nous
permet de nous rencontrer et je pense
que ton regard ta grande gueule ton
caractère peut peut-être moi m'éclairer
et on peut peut-être débat justement
quand on parle des génies du parc comme
moi je trouve absolument insupportable
non moi j'ai mis ayem pas parce que
voilà parce que c'est pas ça suffit pas
forcément d'être intelligent et d'être
beau com de com et ayem ici il faut
beaucoup bossé et relations
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
je ne sais pas pour vous mais moi je
suis fan de si on voit ce paquet ce qui
se passe je me dis nous parce que moi je
vois tes paroles bah voilà exactement là
parce que sous les herbes comme ça un
peu un peu d'air je travaille quand même
voilà il s'assoit un teubé disons que je
meurs et après tu es comme on l'a tous
dit était une très bonne animatrice
voilà après donc tu as forcément des
problèmes d'ego j'imagine parce que lego
va avec avec l'ambition est après il
faut s'intégrer dans une équipe c'est
pas forcément facile voilà même si ceux
de leurs mots et castaldi ont très bien
réussi et donc je te souhaite d'avoir la
même réussite
et puis comme je sais que dcb terre j'ai
environt peu de tourner ma pancarte
c'était non à la base évitez de mettre
des gens dans les cases pour une fois un
petit peu du bien parce que je veux dire
un moment donné à m
elle a tué personne elle a fait du mal à
personne elle insulte personnelle elle
fait que du bien autour d'elle c'est
quelqu'un de très gentil
elle a une bonne réputation en interne
et en externe dont les gens ont tendance
à trop juger le physique important de le
dire parce que mentir non moi je pense
que ça mérite pas autant autant de haine
sur internet c'est vrai que sur les
réseaux sociaux construits ça a été
vraiment un déferlement
après ayem est ce que ça t'a touché ce
que tu lis des sur twitter ou pas du
tout tu t'es dit non je vais prouver aux
gens que j'ai ma place j'ai lu des
choses sur twitter qui sont complètement
à l'opposé de ce que j'ai pu lire sur
instagram sur instagram j'ai le plein de
beaux messages j'ai posté une photo
hier où j'étais complètement détente
avec mon costume de chouettes
donc je ne vais pas prouvé plus comment
dire le côté aux hôtes de jauzion jouit
joyeuse autour des régions ou des
visions total j'étais en costume de
chouette avec la tête comme ça à côté
j'ai posté un truc j'ai remercié civile
parce que je tiens à le remercier germée
c'est l'équipe de tpm paix kim a super
bien la cuillère après pour ceux qui
mettent des mauvais message je ne peux
pas faire l'unanimité et je ne prétends
pas faire l'unanimité
qu'est-ce que qu'est ce que vous pensez
à mener dans touche pas à mon poste
qu'est ce que je peux
amenez je pense qu'aujourd'hui on est
dans une ère de la télévision où il en
faut pour tous les goûts
ayem est ce que toi tu connais bien les
missions est-ce que tu le regardes est
régulièrement est ce que tu peux pas
rater ristic est là moi je connais très
bien les missions et pourrait juste
précédemment sur une émission j'ai
toujours revendiqué et assumé totalement
que civil et sans vouloir faire de la
lèche et je vais le dire en toute
transparence
il a été pour nous un leader que ce soit
pour toutes les personnes qui ont fait
de la télé qui on voulait être animateur
chroniqueur co animateur on a tous pris
exemple sur ces villes parce qu'il a eu
une fulgurance et est un succès
indéniable qu'on a tous vécu et garde
contre fulgurances de jean-michel non
mais vraiment été un modèle pour nous
pendant des années et ça allait encore
donc vraiment oui vous bien sûr j'ai
regardé l'émission
et bien sûr je m'en inspire et même au
quotidien quand j'étais sur nrj que
j'étais animatrice échos quotidien on
devait s'inspirer de certaines choses
bien sûr qu'on s'en rend compte
s'inspirer de cyril de ce qui faisait de
son contenu de ces attitudes de 6
rigolade aliev inspiré s'il est ce que
tu aurais à dire aux téléspectateurs qui
ont voilà pour le voilà de ton arrivée
pour les convaincre que c'est une bonne
idée voilà ta petite à 30 secondes sur
cette caméra là tu leur durée quoi je
pense que on ne peut pas faire
l'unanimité
après je trouve très dur et très
difficile toute cette déferlante de
haine qui peut y avoir sur les réseaux
sociaux sans même avoir laissé la chance
à la personne de faire ses preuves et je
terminerai avec une phrase mon père me
disait tout le temps ça quand on plaît à
tout le monde sait qu'on ne plaît à
personne
je crois que c'est sacha guitry qui
disait ça c'est mon papa qui me
rappelait tout le temps cette phrase et
je veux juste te dire un truc sic balle
et c'est moins fermé près avec pied
après on jugera c'est bien sacha guitry
ça il me semble c'est celui là
c'est une très belle chose sacha et ce
chèque est trié xoom ont recours aux non
jeûneurs